keep it together wordsmiths that's right
the word in this video is
conserve
conserve it's a verb and it means to
keep something safe to protect a natural
resource you might also see it in its
noun form conservation as in animal
conservation let's break this word down
into its two parts con means with or
together like confident or
congratulate and serve comes from the
Latin serere which means to guard or
watch So based on these word Parts
conserve literally means to guard or
watch together let's come up with some
similar words that have these elements
con and serve I'll put on some music and
give you 10 seconds ready here we go
meet you back in
[Music]
10 here's what I came up with preserve
another way to protect to stop something
before it happens pre meaning before
right so I'm protecting it before
something happens if I preserve fruit
I've made it into Jam before it can rot
right Conservatory which is like
conserve plus aor meaning a place for a
conservatory is a greenhouse where
plants are protected from outdoor
weather and Observatory OB means towards
or in front of and an Observatory is a
looking place a building with a big
telescope that you can use to watch the
stars and the planets it is pointed
towards the heavens let's point away
from the heavens and towards some
example sentences that use the word
conserve to conserve water during the
drought we don't take baths just showers
so I'm saving water right there's a big
communal Reservoir somewhere in my town
and I'm using less of it by taking a
shower instead of a bath and that means
that there's water left over to say put
out fires but there's also that other
use I talked about conservation which
has a political meaning usually it's
about a group of people who come
together for environmental reasons to
protect a natural place thus emelo
joined up with the conservation effort
to protect the sand dunes the
conservationists are working to protect
the dunes to keep them safe from threats
or development or pollution conservation
is all about protecting a place and
keeping it safe and
unchanged you always conserve the spirit
of learning within yourselves wordsmiths
because I believe that with it you can
learn anything daveid out